et notre première invitée politique ce
matin c'est philippe dallier bonjour
suite vous allez bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sénateurs les
républicains de la seine-saint-denis
vice-président du sénat encore pour
quelques heures
au moins on est ensemble pendant une
quinzaine de minutes pour une interview
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal jalabert
bonjour pascal des journaux du groupe
ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france philippe dallier d'abord quel
bilan vous faites des sénatoriales pour
votre groupe bien écouté ils sont 54
sénateurs alors que nous partions 244
dans nos estimations les plus hautes
nous ne l'espérions pas donc s'il ya un
groupe politique qui a remporté cette
élection sénatoriale c'est bien le
groupe des républicains
une très bonne surprise une très très
bonne surprise est alliée aux centristes
la majorité sénatoriale sort
véritablement renforcée elle est la
gagnante de cette élection parce qu'ils
y reçoivent en début de soirée on nous
refaisait le coup des écolos qui
progresse et ceram enfin il faut
regarder les choses si nous gagnons des
sièges c'est bien parce que certains en
perdent
les socialistes en perdent la république
en marchant père les radicaux de gauche
en perdent
certes y'a la constitution de ce groupe
écologiste mais c'est à la marge tout
cela et c'est bien d'ailleurs la suite
des municipales parce que là aussi je
vais le redire nous avons gagné les
municipales et sur le deuxième tour avec
le résultat de quelques grandes
métropoles où effectivement les
écologistes ont remporté 11 certains
donner le sentiment que c'était là le
fait politique majeur non le fait
politique majeur poste municipal c'est
bien le net renforcement de la majorité
sénatoriale et les nerfs qui ont
municipal ont remporté près de 60% des
biens sur ses habitants un mot sur lyon
puis ce qu'on vient d'entendre quentin
nous faire un bilan sur cette élection
dans le rhône où la droite était divisé
alors certes vous avez gagné des sièges
mais ce que vous payez vos divisions est
ce que vous auriez pu remporter plus
heureuse justement oui puisque allions
nous avons perdu un siège
mais c'est toujours la même règle
lorsque nous sommes unis et le mode de
scrutin effectivement favorise les
listes qui ceux qui sont importantes en
termes de nombre de voix et donc nous
avons perdu un siège dans le rhône
ça s'est produit également dans le camp
d'en face on peut aller on ne peut que
le regretter
la victoire lui était encore plus belles
155 sénateurs
est-ce que c'est aussi un peu le fruit
du travail de contre pouvoir et
d'opposition on va dire qu'il est ni
pavlovienne ni évidemment
systématiquement avec le gouvernement
qui a payé avec gérard larcher à la tête
du sénat et bruno retailleau à la tête
du groupe je crois que nous avons un
tandem qui permet à cette majorité de
travailler est très loin de la
caricature que certains parfois veulent
donner
il suffit de regarder ce qui s'est passé
au sénat dans les six derniers mois
depuis la crise du commises nous avons
travaillé effectivement pour adopter des
textes dans l'urgence pour les modifier
mais au bout du compte on a trouvé un
accord avec l'assemblée nationale donc
nous nous opposons mais pas j'allais
dire effectivement dans un réflexe
pavlovien pas par définition parce que
nous sommes dans l'opposition
nous faisons notre travail de
législateur le sénat de travail il a
toujours travaillé
il a souvent été critiqué injustement
mais je crois que nous vivons une
période où tout d'un coup un certain
nombre de commentateurs ou de français
s'aperçoivent de l'utilité du sénat
gérard larcher dit on ne dit jamais oui
par dogmatisme jamais non par discipline
et je vous allez rester sur cette ligne
alors qu'on va arriver dans une période
très politique avec la présidentielle
qui va approcher durant ces trois années
est ce que vous allez rester sur cette
ligne ou est ce que vous dites la droite
a besoin d'imprimer quelle est la
première force d'opposition
nous sommes la première force
d'opposition mais dans le travail
législatif
il y a le moyen d'affirmer ses positions
par voie d'amendement pour faire adopter
un certain nombre de dispositions ici
mais pour autant nous ne sommes pas dans
l'opposition systématique
bon ceci étant dit nous allons rentrer
dans la discussion de la loi de finances
c'est un moment extrêmement important eu
égard au contexte économique et sociale
dans le pays et
auront l'occasion de dire un certain
nombre de choses et de critiquer ce que
le gouvernement est en train de nous
proposer parce qu'on nous a beaucoup
parlé d'un plan de relance mais quand on
regarde ce qui est proposé
beaucoup s'inquiètent et nous nous
inquiétions donc nous allons avoir
l'occasion de le dire et de le dire
fermement parce que c'est aussi cela
notre rôle
oui pardon oui cette démonstration que
la droite et le centre unis ont bien
fonctionné
allez-vous milité pour qu'elle soit
aussi appliqué aux régionales
départementales et à la présidentielle
puisque dans huit mois on est en
campagne présidence la présidentielle
c'est autre chose
les institutions sont ainsi faites mais
des bien évident que pour les
départementales et régionales à venir au
printemps prochain
je pense qu'il ya quelques leçons à
tirer du résultat de ces élections
sénatoriales oui lorsque nous sommes
unis nous sommes plus forts et donc nous
allons tenter d'incarner encore une fois
dans nos territoires
cette alternative cette autre vision des
territoires parce que on voit bien le
dit le groupe la république en marche va
changer de nom pour s'appeler
renaissance est territoire ça me fait un
peu rigoler excusez moi donc ça leur
naissance ils ont fait rage dans les
territoires ils les ont méprisé pendant
tout le début du quinquennat pour
s'apercevoir maintenant de leur utilité
donc nous allons nous incarnons ici avec
nos alliés centristes l'alternance et
l'opposition et nous allons il s'agit
effectivement sur le terrain de la
république en marche présente ces
territoires alors qu'on sait que la
droite depuis des années nous répète
qu'elle veut faire la reconquête par les
territoires est ce que le fait qu'ils ne
changent de nom ici au sénat pour mettre
le mot territoire ça vous inquiète sur
la ligne qui est aussi incarné par jean
castex qu'il entrevoit la bouche ça n'a
strictement aucune importance c'est pas
parce que on change le nom du groupe
d'ailleurs je pense qu'en termes de
visibilité ne plus appeler la république
hors marché appelé renaissance et
territoires on veut plus personne ne va
rien y comprendre
mais ce ne sont pas les mots qui sont
importants c'est la réalité du terrain
et sur le terrain regardez les élus
locaux et et regarder deux qui se
sentent proches aujourd'hui très
majoritairement on en a eu la
démonstration hier les élus locaux les
élus de nos territoires se sentent
beaucoup plus proche de la majorité
sénatoriale que deux
majorité monsieur s'excluent dons pour
les régionales des alliances des listes
communes avec elles mêmes et les
candidats de centre bell pour moi ça
exclut effectivement des alliances avec
lrm d'ailleurs enfin regardons là aussi
la leçon des municipales
ce qui chez nous on était tenté par des
alliances avec lrm certains l'ont payé
très cher il faut de la clarté
voilà nous sommes dans l'opposition nous
ne sommes pas dans l'opposition
systématique mais il faut de la clarté
nous n'incarnons pas la même ligne
politique que celle du président de la
république il y avait des républicains
notamment sur l'analyse de sébastien
lecornu dans l'eure est ce que vous
craignez que le sénat soit le
laboratoire d'une recomposition de la
majorité qui va tenter de se tourner
vers la droite sébastien lecornu aurait
voulu jouer les apprentis sorciers
puisque effectivement il avait même
annoncé qu'il visait la présidence du
sénat excusez moi il a remporté un siège
lorsque certains lui en donnait 2 1 peut
pas dire que ce soit un franc succès
donc j'allais dire pour son rôle
d'apprenti sorcier il repassera ça veut
dire qu'il ne pourra pas briguer la
présidence sénat est pas pas tout de
suite mais il visait plutôt 2023 vote
2026 fin 2023 26 c dans un siècle
politiquement parlant donc nous verrons
pour vous pour vous son et les aléas les
ratés pour vous son élection à sébastien
lecornu raté parce qu'il n'a réalisé
qu'un sièges alors qu'il en visait 2
voilà donc toutes ces combinaisons
apparaissent souvent comme de l'art à
tatouille politique et force est de
constater en tous les cas que les
électeurs ne sont pas forcément sensible
le retour d'un groupe écologiste au
sénat même si un peu mathématiques par
rapport aux municipales
ça va obliger peut-être le sénat se
penche un peu plus sur ces questions
d'environnement ça va un peu vous
secouer je trouve que vous êtes assez
injuste en disant que ça va obliger le
sénat à se pencher sur ces sujets là
regardez un peu les rapports
parlementaires produit ici beaucoup
traite de ce sujet maintenant l'écologie
sans ce groupe politique du terme c'est
souvent très compliqué enfin tous les
cas on a pu le constater dans le passé
donc ils sont
douzaine si j'aimais compris qui avec
quatre sénateurs écologistes ils
reviennent à 12 ils ont pris ces sièges
essentiellement au parti socialiste ou
aux radicaux de gauche
donc ça n'est pas un bouleversement donc
qu'ils ont un groupe inchangé par le
sénat lesquels ils ont un groupe donc
voilà mais enfin 12 sénateurs sur 348 on
ne peut pas considérer non plus que ce
soient la révolution l'autre information
c'est une première c'est un nationaliste
qui va faire son entrée ici au sénat un
élu en haute-corse qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
d'ailleurs on me dit qu'il siégera au
groupe écologiste paraît un peu étonnant
mais enfin c'est ce qu'on nous annonce
écoutez il sera seul ce que j'espère
c'est que son discours s'inscrira dans
le cadre de notre république parce que
parfois parfois déjà le cas avec un
certain nombre de nos collègues
d'outre-mer je ne citerai pas de nom
mais qui tiennent ici dans l'hémicycle
un discours qui parfois surprend et
parfois même choque un peu voilà c'est
le sénat de la république française et à
une surprise hier c'est stéphane ravier
qui a conservé son siège qui était le
seul sénateur du rassemblement national
et qui restera le seul sénateur du
rassemblement national mais bon dans les
bouches du rhône il a privé la droite
d'un quatrième siège ça s'est joué à
rien à 33,20 est-ce que vous pensez que
localement il ya des élus de droite qui
ont voté pour stéphane ravier août et je
n'en sais rien et vous n'en savez rien
dans les bouches du rhône
tous les cas ce que je vois d'assez loin
tout de même c'est que l'âme et de la
création de la métropole marseille aix a
beaucoup inquiété les petites communes
et certains de mes collègues me disent
qu effectivement stéphane ravier
probablement a fait des voix dans ces
petites communes des bouches du rhône
qui regardent la métropole comme un
objet un peu inquiétant quand vas tu
parles de droite écoutez vous savez la
grande majorité aujourd'hui des élus
locaux n'ont pas ne sont pas encarté
politiquement et ça il faut vraiment que
comme en prennent conscience et même
dans un département comme le mien la
zone lundi
de plus en plus de conseillers
municipaux s'en sont sans appartenances
partisanes et donc après allez dire ce
sont ceux ci mme ceux là qui ont voté
ainsi c'est extrêmement compliqué oui le
premier texte que vous allez examiner
enfin le premier grand texte
évidemment le budget de la nation puis
celui de la sécurité sociale donc avec
le fameux plan de relance va t'il assez
loin ce plan je pense qu'il ya
effectivement matière matière à discuter
nous sommes dans une crise qui est
extraordinaire - 10 ou moins 2% sur le
pipe la dette publique qui s'envole le
gouvernement qui a effectivement a pris
un certain nombre de dispositions pour
soutenir les entreprises et les salariés
et la question maintenant c'est l'étape
d'après est ce que les mesures qui nous
sont proposés sont véritablement un plan
de relance
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un plan de
relance ce sont des mesures dont on
attendait effet immédiat donc est-ce que
les mesures proposées vont dans cette
direction là moi je m'interroge sur un
certain nombre d'entre elles
c'est vrai qu'on peut imaginer baisser
les impôts de production une dizaine de
milliards de moins
mais l'effet de cette baisse va se faire
ressentir dans le temps est ce que ces
10 milliards ne serait pas mieux utilisé
et puis il ya probablement à prendre en
considération les mesures qui vont
manifestement duré c'est dans un certain
nombre de secteurs voient bien la fronde
qui se lève du côté des restaurateurs
etc
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui vont
tout simplement se trouvait en danger de
mort très rapidement donc est ce qu'il
vaut pas mieux utilisé cet argent public
pour annuler les cotisations sociales ou
des dettes contractées par ces
entreprises il ya vraiment matière à
débat on va parler de vous fier d'aller
vous êtes actuellement vice-président du
sénat vous ne pourrez pas leur me
représenter au sein du groupe
c'est la règle du groupe g la règle du
groupe quels nouveaux pass vous
souhaitez occuper dans ce nouveau sénat
écoutez mes collègues du groupe le
réputé en décideront mais j'ai
effectivement je vais proposer ma
candidature pour le poste de rapporteur
général du budget vous pensez que ça
sera bon les actions une élection est
une élection
rendez vous lundi
5 octobre c'est est rapporteur général
du budget blayau lui a dit déjà dès hier
soir qu'il souhaitait rester président
de votre groupe
il est déjà un peu lancé pour la
présidentielle est ce que il peut rester
président du groupe en étant candidat
putatif à la présidentielle écoutez si
cela se fait effectivement il aura des
décisions à prendre et je pense qu'il en
est éminemment conscient voilà mais nous
ne sommes pas encore rentré dans la
présidentielle c'est aussi cela que je
voudrais souligner et à mon avis les
français ne sont pas du tout entrer dans
la présidentielle
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est la crise et
la manière pour lacombe à l'inquiétude
des français pour beaucoup d'entre eux
c'est de savoir comment la fia la fin de
l'année ils pourront conserver leur
emploi ou s'ils vont le perdre à cause
de la multiplication des plans sociaux
elle est là l'urgence donc je pense que
la présidentielle et puis au moins
denses rechargeant bruno retailleau peut
être président sans aucune difficulté je
le souhaite d'ailleurs
et puis nous aurons au moins de mars
prochain les départementales et
régionales
la présidentielle viendra après est ce
que vous craignez que les ambitions
bruno retailleau et son positionnement
plutôt à droite fasse partir certains
sénateurs de valeron écouter regarder le
résultat que nous avons obtenu
je le redis encore une fois le tandem
jara larcher à la présidence du sénat et
bruno retailleau à la tête du groupe
fonctionne extrêmement bien extrêmement
bien et je constate que dans le passé
très peu de sénateurs ont fait le choix
de quitter le groupe
et là nous progressons donc c'est quand
même un bilan remarquable très bien
alors après le budget vous allez devoir
aborder d'autres grands textes notamment
sur la sécurité sociale quelles mesures
d'urgence voyez-vous pour amortir cette
crise justement le financement de la
sécurité sociale
et puis on pourrait aussi parler de la
part des retraites le système des
retraites
ce sont des sujets qui pour le moment on
était 1000 côté le goût
moment c'était en partie nécessaire fait
comme si l'argent public pouvait couler
à flot sans qu'à un moment donné il
fallait prendre en considération tout
cela moi je tire la sonnette d'alarmé et
il ne faudrait pas que les français
croient qu effectivement on peut
continuer par centaines de milliards à
distribuer l'argent public un dernier
mot sur un des liens poste puisque le
renouvellement s'impose à tout le monde
au sein de votre groupe y compris à
philippe bas le président de la
commission des lois est ce que il doit
rester philippe bas président de cette
commission
il faut changer il y a une règle qui a
été édictée elle m'empêche de me
représenter comme vice-président du
sénat et elle empêche célibat de se
représenter à la tête de la commission
des lois
le groupe va se réunir très
prochainement je pense que ce sujet sera
débattu je ne peux pas vous dire ce
qu'il en sortira pour vous il ne doit
pas être candidat il doit respecter le
renouvellement on va on va en débattre
peut-être que ces règles ont été pris
sans bien en mesurer les conséquences à
l'époque pour autant aujourd'hui elle
s'impose là on est dans une difficulté
j'ai beaucoup de steam pour philippe bas
et c'est un vrai problème
merci beaucoup on suivra tout ça merci
beaucoup